how old were you when you did
last comic standing let me see i was
probably
five years into the game when i did that
and
and they kicked you off right well i
snuck in a blackberry that goes to show
right there i had a blackberry cell
phone
uh those were those were the [ __ ] back
then the blackberry
and i snuck it in to stay in touch with
my girl and they caught me
texting her it wasn't like some people
said oh well he's probably getting jokes
from the outside i'm like really i'm
like i came into the show
already being like that guy that was
considered the uh
the the ringer on the show and i'm like
i was just trying to stay in touch
making sure somebody else wasn't with
her
well that's why i brought the phone uh
yes i got caught and i got kicked off
the show i told people that i made
history
being the first mexican ever deported
off nbc
yeah [ __ ] man it worked out you know i
don't
anybody who won the show very few people
actually
made a big career out of winning the
show it's usually the people that
came in second or third or got kicked
off early that
went on to do something right getting
kicked off for smuggling in a cell phone
is a better story i think he probably
got more people aware of that
than a lot of the people who won it
[Music]
yeah dude